thank you adam well uh the conclusions
from alex allen are out and so
is the prime minister's verdict i'll
start with the advice that's just been
published from sir alex
allen the senior civil servant looking
into pretty hell's behavior
he says uh my advice is that the home
secretary
has not consistently met the high
standards required by the ministerial
code of treating her civil servants
with consideration and respect her
approach on occasions has amounted to
behavior
that can be described as bullying in
terms of the
impact felt by individuals a heavily
caveated statement there you see
to that extent her behavior has been in
breach of the ministerial code
if even if unintentionally this
conclusion needs to be seen in a context
there is no evidence that she was aware
of the impact of her
behavior and no feedback was given to
her at the time
this high pressure and the high pressure
and demands of the role in the home
office coupled with the need for more
supportive leadership from the top of
the department has clearly been a
contributory factor
in particular i note the finding of
different and more positive behavior
since these issues were raised with her
now the prime minister has had those
conclusions
on his desk for a while here's what he
says this is
boris johnson today the prime minister
notes alex's advice
that there are many of the concerns were
not raised at the time and that the home
secretary was unaware of the impact
that her behavior had the prime minister
is rachel reassured uh uh
that the home secretary is sorry for
inadvertently upsetting those
with whom she was working he is also
reassured that
relationships practices and the culture
in the home office are much
improved as the arbiter of the code
having considered sir alex's advice and
weighed up all the factors the prime
minister's judgment
is that the ministerial code was not
breached
now that's different to what you just
heard sir alex say he then goes on to
conclude the prime minister has full
confidence
in the home secretary and considers this
matter now closed he's grateful to
thousands of civil servants working
extremely hard
to support delivery of the government's
priorities so those two key bits again
is the prime minister's arbiter of the
code having considered alex's advice
he has judged that the ministerial code
has not been breached that appears to
contradict what we just heard from alex
allen
he said uh that um uh uh
uh in that uh to in it to that extent
her behavior has been
a breach of the ministerial code it's as
clear as light and day alex allen is
saying she wrote the code
boris johnson is saying taking
everything into account i'm not so sure
i don't think she did
there are reports now that uh alex allen
is considering his feature we'll
check those out and get back to you but
a serious moment for boris johnson as
effectively
he overrules the siemo senior ethics
advisor
in his government also interesting isn't
it because
by saying she hasn't broken the
ministerial code
uh he's actually leaving in place the
possibility that if she had
broken the ministerial code she should
have had to resign that's the way
he's uh got her off the charge if you
like
it it is up to a point adam but alex
allen in black and white has said
uh that she broke the code and we
understand that alex allen has resigned
uh as the advisor uh in the cabinet
office uh
are the most senior person in charge of
propriety and ethics for boris johnson
another
complication uh in this round for uh the
prime minister
yes the prime minister says there are
lots of mitigating factors
yes the prime minister says that the
home office hadn't supported her the
prime minister weighs
heavily on the fact that uh pretty patel
didn't know she was bullying people
because she wasn't told she was bullying
people by the people
presumably some of whom she was bullying
and those are the grounds on under which
boris johnson decides that she hasn't
broken the ministerial code
but ultimately the prime minister will
always remain the arbiter of the
ministerial code
uh and has decided that priti patel
neither broke the code uh nor
um should go from her job uh pretty
patel we understand has upon uh has
apologized and we are waiting uh for
that statement
uh imminently uh so uh apparently alex
allen resigned because the pm ignored
uh his advice according to she says i am
sorry that my behavior in the past uh
has uh upset people
it has never been my intention to cause
upset to anyone
i am very grateful for the hard work of
thousands of civil servants who helped
to deliver
the government's agenda i care deeply
about delivering on the commitments that
we have made to the people of this
country
and i acknowledge that i am direct
and have at times got frustrated i would
like to thank the prime minister for his
support
the permanent secretary and i are
working closely
uh together to deliver on the vital job
the home office
has to do for the country and uh that's
interesting sam because the normal
formula of these apologies is to say i
am sorry if
my behavior blah blah blah but in this
case she accepts it she says
i am sorry my behavior has upset people
so she's not trying to deny it
absolutely um there are more than one
extraordinary feature of
of this breaking story we have just seen
on the government website
the resignation statement of the ethics
advisor to the prime minister
let me read it to you now this page
contains a statement from sir alex allen
who wrote the report that found that
pretty patel did break the ministerial
code
he says i recognize that it is for the
prime minister to make a judgment on
whether actions by a minister amount to
a breach the ministerial code
but i feel that it is right that i
should now resign from my position
as the prime minister's independent
advisor
on the code now that means that he is
going from his role as ethics advisor we
are
uh we believe he's gone more widely uh
from his position but we'll be checking
that out over the next half an hour
clearly the prime minister's setting
himself at odds
with the civil service today the civil
servant
the civil service verdict was there was
a breach of the ministerial code because
of bullying
the prime minister decided that there
were sufficient mitigating factors
uh to keep her in her job she has issued
an apology
for past behavior as you say slightly
circumscribed slightly
limited in what it's actually replying
for and what we don't have of course
is perhaps a more detailed report from
alex allen going through specific
incidents
that he looked into not clear whether
that exists as a stand-alone document
uh that might be published in future
through freedom of information or
perhaps through um
uh emerging through leaking uh that goes
into what alex allen actually found in
the specific
but today we have a situation where
boris johnson says that pretty patel can
stay in her job
after she was found to have breached the
code by his advisors but he decided that
they were wrong
i mean this is an extraordinary
situation sam because my understanding
of the ministerial code has always
been that it was left to senior civil
servants the cabinet secretary and those
he deputes
to take the decision on the
technicalities what the ministerial code
was
and whether ministers had breached it
and precisely to maintain the
independence of the whole system but now
we have the prime minister saying well i
don't care uh what if you like the
official judges have decided i'm
overruling them
you're right adam although to be honest
there's always an amount of citizen you
have to apply to the entire
independent ministerial code process uh
it exists as a convenience for the prime
minister
sometimes prime ministers want to
forgive and keep their cabinet ministers
in post
and be able to say that an independent
process has found uh that that
um uh that that process uh has let the
let the individual minister off the hook
and then the prime minister can simply
go along with it
sometimes the prime minister can say
well i didn't do the investigation an
independent process did
and that's why i'm having to fire you uh
but that element of distance
uh always questionable in these uh
situations
has never resulted in a public dispute
between a breaking uh between one
uh uh individual the head of the sort of
advice
deciding that the minister broke the
code and the prime minister deciding
that they didn't break the code even if
the minister themselves uh is put in the
position uh of uh uh
even if then uh he decides not to
minister concerned
this is tricky for boris johnson we are
now uh at the end
of reset week uh where we were told
after the departure of dominic cummings
and some of his vote leave uh
crew that we were going to get something
of a different tone from the prime
minister
what this does this incident is that it
will ratchet up tensions between
whitehall and the prime minister because
of the stark nature
of the difference of opinion over what
happened in the past
and what should happen uh going forward
uh
and uh boris johnson again spending more
political capital rather like he did
with dominic cummings earlier in the
year
um uh having to wade in and defend a
cabinet minister
uh or somebody who he's close to who
is uh who is in trouble clearly is in
trouble because the independent ethics
adviser
uh investigated her conduct and found uh
that it was
uh and decided that he was gonna spend
more of that political capital
uh uh in defending her now on
helping him is the fact that this is
turning in
quite frankly to a partisan fight with
tories
from the moderate wing of the
conservative party even including uh tom
tugan hat
uh the moderate chair of the foreign
affairs committee uh weighing in on
pretty patel's behalf through you heard
boris john um buena jenkin the chair of
the uh uh
of a senior select committee uh also
saying that uh uh
that uh clearly the verdict on her
behavior was more nuanced and therefore
she shouldn't go
so there's strong backing and he's able
to point at labor and say they're the
people
uh that basically make this into a sort
of party political divide of an issue
only one lone voice roger gail even
querying any of the aspects of
what's going on today from the tory
benches uh
but nevertheless the decision of boris
johnson to hang on to pretty patel
even after an independent investigation
found that she breached the ministerial
code
um she's undoubtedly a very popular
figure amongst the tory grassroots she's
a hardline uh home secretary
uh who got rousing uh uh cheers at her
first
party conference just over a year ago
she's a difficult figure
uh to sack um but boris johnson himself
was the
prime minister who put a forward on the
ministerial code saying you break these
rules you're out
she was found to have broken the rules
boris johnson had to overrule that
change that verdict in order to keep her
in post